[Music]
[Music]
from the very beginning the governor was
allowing covet positive patients to be
placed in the same nursing home as
covent
negative patients many in the
legislature disagreed and went to work
to try and change the policy
but the governor now has vetoed it
governor whitmer is still standing by
our policy of placing
covet positive patients in nursing homes
with people who are covet negative there
hasn't been
one nursing home that has taken a covet
19 patient that they didn't think that
they were prepared to care for
across the state nursing homes are not
prepared with enough ppe
i'd like to hear what data was relied on
to pick
nursing homes to bring in covet patients
to infect those that weren't infected to
kill those loved ones
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
that's a stressful sip yeah the little i
know right it's a stressful sip because
uh for people sorry that we've started
late we are still locked out of facebook
i can't stream there so let everyone on
facebook know when youtube wasn't
working but we we got you uh that's what
we have
we're always able to stream at mug club
if one of the streams in the future does
not work louder with crowder.com
club also governor whitmer we're coming
for you
we're coming for you october 2nd we're
gonna be in the backyard
technically it's my backyard you're just
visiting my uh
half asian lawyer bill richmond hello
speaking of which
foreshadowing quarterback garrett how
are you good morning what's going on
didn't have a heart attack there with
the effects a little bit
i think he did yeah yeah three or four
that's very urban of you audio wade
gerald a uh listen no secret here we'll
be talking about we'll be talking about
what's going on in kentucky
that's not good i would like to say that
it's out of the norm nowadays folks but
let's be honest
uh and then we'll also be talking about
donald trump how he will not
peaceably transfer power is what the
media
uh well it's total [ __ ]
good reason um and i have a question for
you before we get to all of that
have you noticed now that almost every
single time not at almost every single
time the story that we get from the
media and these black lives matter the
police shootings
are verifiably false yeah just like
every sk
you know what they parallel every
scandal with donald trump
russia verifiably false also
exactly and uh the news media never
covers the correct version
right very well yeah i like to cover the
version that they want that will help
with their talking points
yes still no mention of hunter biden by
the way inside oh i've been watching
really
not mentioned it apparently it's not a
big deal to use the uh
wife of the mayor of moscow's 3.5
million dollars for
sex slaves tomato
uh before we move on let's look at cnn
what they're saying about brianna taylor
in kentucky
i love louisville kentucky i gave birth
to my two children here
i may die here but you know what
i have found the thing that i am willing
to
is she wearing chains yes she's wearing
chase
now is this really what we're doing now
wearing chains oh
can you believe the this is getting
carrot top level
it's scary if carrot top didn't
understand
the subject that he was covering okay
let's get to brianna taylor
and uh why about everything you know is
wrong let me be clear here
i would consider this a tragedy because
all around
i wish that this hadn't happened uh
briana taylor
should not have been shot absolutely not
right okay
they shouldn't have been shooting
through door there was confusion but the
anyone who assumes that this is because
of racism
is an idiot all right anyone who
believes that brianna taylor was
sleeping in her bed
no that the police came with a no-knock
warrant no and that they
initiated the opening fire no what
happened was they knocked announced
themselves said hey police
guy was shooting they tried to break
through the door return fire brianna
taylor dead we'll get into the specifics
but anyone who thinks that this tragedy
is due to racism
it's blind fire
it's impossible to be racist at that
point um so of course there's been
protests i'm not going to say protests
i'm going to say riots
rights right thank you
this lady knows with her ghost rider
chain whip um
she took the chains off for this
interview though it's good
they charged one of the officers right
one of the three officers involved with
uh they charged him with wanton
endangerment because he he
fired his weapon and it put people at
risk and they're saying well
why didn't they just charge him for
murdering brianna taylor well because
here's the thing they had a warrant for
brianna taylor's apartment or her
townhouse apartment condo i'm not
entirely sure don't [ __ ] check me on that
i believe it was an apartment
her domicile i don't know if it was a
sublet
it could have been you never know i
would argue it's irrelevant it it might
actually be irrelevant
erroneous to use my uh half channel term
um so wanton endangerment is the charge
which uh by the way i've never heard of
wanton endangerment used outside of one
endangerment or wanton disregard it's
not a word
outside of those legal clubs i did have
to clarify with gerald he thought we
were talking about wonton
and that's just because he's racist that
is true he was an honest mistake he's
tall
white and blonde my brother was grounded
because he refused to eat wonton soup as
a kid one time really
was it was it a principal or at all no
the west view mall food court he
demanded to eat wanton soup because they
had a friend who ate wonton soup and
they said jordan we know that you don't
like
it he said no no no no no i want it if
you don't eat it we're gonna ground you
and you won't be able to see all i want
for christmas which i had the little
drummer from that thing you do and
leslie nielsen
he said no again and then guess what he
missed out on a cinematic
[Laughter]
he's been masterpiece the god true story
cross
my heart and hope to die so this is what
happened
uh but uh then there were of course
these riots here's a montage to start
you off and wet the palate
that's a man protecting his shop
i bet white man protecting his shop
assaulting a car swarming
[Laughter]
that's a courthouse yeah you can tell by
the architecture
yeah the guy said burn it down he's just
imitating don lemon hey chaz
i've been there look at this look at
this that's attempted murder
yep that's attempted murder that's a
weapon
and so is this next one as far as i'm
concerned this is attempted murder oh
yeah
yes there's like 10 15 people right
around that area
walking up and hitting an officer in the
back of the head with a baseball bat
and throwing a molotov cocktail keep in
mind there was no building he could have
reached with his [ __ ] arm
so we know he was aiming for people
absolutely also because he announced it
so you throw effectively homemade napalm
which is what you're trying to do though
you probably
failed get some mohawk get some ever
clear tito's won't cut it
throwing that into a crowd of people and
hitting someone on the back of the head
as hard as you can with a baseball bat
as far as i'm concerned have we reached
the level
especially when happening the cops
attempted murder these people need to be
locked up for a very long time
not saying that's the exact law you can
clarify but that's what
i would like to see if you hit an
officer in the back of a head
with a baseball bat back of the head
could be a two-headed officer
can that be qualified as attempted
murder hitting someone in the back of
the head as hard as you can oh no
so it's a combination of both the action
that they're doing but also the thing
that they're using so if you
swung a pool noodle okay you're not
gonna get attempted murdering swinging
aluminum louisville slugger yeah
absolutely you're
wait i thought a louisville slugger had
to be wooden man i don't know they don't
look like
it's a big you know by the way hold on
you know what the cops uh
the crime was there he it looks like he
had fallen off of his bicycle because he
hit like a little barrier
yeah it wasn't like he was fighting with
protesters it didn't look like initially
from what we saw so he just he fell down
and like oh someone fell down
well notice how he was the cops notice
how uh you know he reacted to being
almost
decapitated right uh he pulled out his
gun and shot everywhere everywhere
he pulled out his pepper spray right and
ran for his life right
which they also of police brutality
right right so this is a department
that's clearly
uh racist to the core and deserving of
burning an entire city well that's the
hallmark of the kkk
is um they walk back while using a
defensive weapon like pepper spray
you ever see when robert byrd did his
crossbow he wouldn't go so much burn
across as he would
knock ding dong ditch and run back with
bear mates
no wonder they were people don't know
their history because you all got fooled
watching roots
so unaware all of this let me and i want
to go to your
your uh your point here again two
officers were shot
in louisville okay yeah this is and this
is going to be the last week that we are
selling these shirts
uh at the lateralcuttershop.com for
david dorn it is open season on
officers lebron james the spineless i
don't want to use the word against
spineless
vagina uh who said he had no comment
on the los angeles uh deputy ambush
really really comment on how to comment
on jacob blake's rape
how about a comment on on any of these
crimes and how about a comment on any of
these
acts of ma of wanting disregard for the
safety or lives of police officers out
there
and i'll talk about this more later oh
mike we don't cover enough i feel
so bad for black police officers and you
see them in all of these videos by the
way
they are completely forgotten they are
the most useless pawn for the media
right now
so they give them no air time what must
it be like right now i'm
during the detroit riots my dad had a
friend who was a police officer
they had friends who were black black
police officers during the riots they
had to go home in unmarked vehicles
i can only imagine what's happening now
well guess what some people do
appreciate you your service is not
completely unappreciated just by pricks
like don lemon who talk about burning it
down see we can bridge the racial divide
and
he can attempt to bridge the sexuality
divide i have no idea
whatever divide he wants he'll be about
as successful as his show despite being
in prime time
this is the story that we were given
okay a no knock warrant this is why we
have the riots right
no knock warrant was issues cop show was
issued cops showed up
didn't knock didn't uh didn't avail
their identity at all didn't even tell
basically
like they were the police bandits all
the greats
no knock warrant that there were no
drugs in the home that brianna taylor
had nothing to do with drugs
and that the cops randomly shot a black
woman sleeping in her
effectively a sleeping bag she was
having a sleepover that's how it was
presented no well
let me break it down for you it wasn't a
no-knock warrant okay
uh she wasn't sleeping and the current
boyfriend in the home with brianna
taylor shot first okay so they want you
to think
that it was a slumber party with just an
officer coming in like commando
when really uh it was more like this
who's there it's the police man we've
got a warrant
i don't know any warren
no no it's we have a warrant
warrant who
no no ma'am we're the police and we have
a
[Music]
and warrant always gets the short end of
the stick wow
poor poor guy well you had to say and
then i want to i want to give some
details i wanted to summarize that for
you so you know that everything is wrong
and then i'll explain to you why in case
you
you know you think i'm like the young
turks or don lemon where i don't provide
any sources
i've brought receipts bill i'm wondering
why the anger
is directed at the police right now i
understand about the the actual event
that happened right but when you take
charges to a grand jury and the grand
jury comes back and says there's no
evidence
shouldn't they be pissed at the people
the people in the city basically that
said hey we looked at all the evidence
and
we can't bring any charges and by the
way we looked at all the evidence with
no defense basically for anybody on the
police force
only the evidence against them
essentially and we said that there
wasn't enough to charge him is that is
that pretty much what happened well yeah
and i mean when you look at any of these
grand juries look no one's gonna no one
on either side is gonna say the grand
jury's always get it right or that they
always go wrong but they get it right
virtually almost all the time i mean the
standards are very low it's pretty easy
to be able to go through if you have the
evidence
right be able to say this is just to
charge the people right but they went
through the process they examined the
evidence and but all the facts we have
show it's the same it's not that the
officer shot first the officers
were there was a shot fired first at
them then they fired back
i actually officer was struck in the leg
by that [ __ ] oh yeah i was
even mentioning this but the young turks
were talking about the the
the people there were not though they
shot at cops one of them was that hurt
in the leg
oh you go get shot you from earlier and
tell me how it
feels well normally what i think when i
get shot in the leg is oh this guy's
done
you know i think oh god you know we had
chris kyle over here just aimed it right
up
you know just got me right the femoral
no big deal let's everyone just like
shake hands at this point
which completely ignores the danger that
officers face and every
given moment i mean there's just a
complete denial of reality of the
dangers of being an officer and how they
put their lives on the line every single
time
whether it was david dorn both before
and after he was a cop right and the
cops every single day yeah but
ultimately when you look at what
happened in this particular situation no
one denies that if you're in the dark
and you're firing
shots maybe we can be critical if they
didn't say it loud enough or if it turns
out it's true they didn't say anything
but there's no evidence to that well
one thing i want to be clear about the
boyfriend did say that they knocked
yeah they knocked he said i don't he
said that he didn't hear them
saying that they were police now the
official order
was changed for the warrant i want to be
clear because we even covered the story
where we said the police claimed that
they
uh stated who they were right no the
order was changed from a no-knock
warrant
before they went out and the boyfriend
has already said
they did knock on the door and we now
know that brianna taylor was not asleep
they were both awake and alert in the
hallway so the only argument and it's my
word versus theirs an official order
that was no
that wasn't a no-knock warrant um is did
they
say uh policeman did they say that
right that's the only that's the only uh
fact that's in question at this point i
want to be clear about that that's
yeah right and so when we look at the
charges themselves
uh look every person who owns a gun even
police officers
themselves are gonna say yes there's no
question that there's adrenaline no
question that you're gonna
you know fire your weapon and you know
there's no rule about how many times you
fire shots they always want to talk
about how many times they were firing
well you have
you fire when you perceive the danger
and you continue to fire until
it appears that the danger is no longer
there and the fact that they took the
the ability to look at the different
officers it wasn't even the officer who
got charged with the wanton endangerment
he wasn't even the one that shot the
most right now one of the other ones
shot significantly more bullets
but it was how he did it and why he did
it so the fact that they said again it's
not to say
he's trying to shoot kobe
[Applause]
but this is actually an example of how
the system does work
this is when you're analyzing the actual
facts as opposed to the feelings okay
and saying okay it is a tragedy look
what the a.g said he goes it's a tragedy
that she died there's no doubt about it
but that doesn't mean we
compound that with additional tragedies
of law by charging people and we've
already compounded it with additional
tragedies from the media so like i said
this is an example of the
law working it doesn't always work but
in this in this case
more truth has come to light we waited
for facts but it shows us that the media
is not working that that is a broken
system because
look right now they don't care well
they're back to covet for a little bit
they still think they do
they don't care what the truth is they
don't
cover that it's a hate crime hoax
whether it's smallet
or bubba watkins or poop swastika or the
duke lacrosse team
or mattress girl they just cover the
initial lie today they're going to
double down in the lie
let the riots burn for a little bit have
some democrats on there talking about
how they have the
how they're empathetic and then they
will move on their merry way because
there's no accountability but as it
relates to the law
also um uh mrs rbg i believe you have a
a
a beach party uh at your beach house
this weekend yes i just signed a new
lease on uh
a wonderful beach house down by the
water
well you know what in this market you
should buy
a couple of facts here that uh it wasn't
a no-knock warrant
i just was really clear about that uh i
think we have uh an overlay uh
for that uh it changed the official
order changed
okay police served weren't at the
residence of briana taylor this is it's
a little bit confusing i don't want to
get too nerdy
there was a drug dealer across town they
also had a warrant that person has been
brought up on charges
he hasn't been convicted yet as far as i
know but if he gets off without being
convicted i will eat my hat i will
find a hat i don't wear hats and i'll
eat it eat it
promise you on air if the guy gets up
with no charges
i'll eat my hat that was walker now the
boyfriend was a man named jamarcus
glover
he is also a convicted drug trafficker
okay brianna taylor had packages sent to
her
residence that was being picked up by
this other drug that's why they had two
uh uh congruent congress concurrent
right concurrent concurrent
contemplation
wanton concurrent uh warrants
for that house and for brianna taylor's
house uh
here's something a lot of people don't
know brennan tale had a dead body in a
rental car in 2016.
that has a whole lot but again it's like
that's a weird thing
it was a very weird was it rbg i have
wow no it would have been back then now
that's awesome
she's still alive it's a hoax but this
[ __ ] she had a dead body in a rental car
that's crazy and again
do you think the cops know that yeah i
rented it this way
but if i knew i was as much well i'd go
all right what's this warrant for okay
they got the other drug dealer across
town right he has a violent history and
uh
dead body and a kia what is this
who does that yeah i need some context
on this oh yeah
well she get her and she and she got her
cleaning deposit back oh
you can't get a bag for that that trunk
is a two-body trunk
i absolutely did because because avis
didn't want a riot
yeah do you have to disclose that on the
form like i have a ding on the
and then left fender that was already
there ma'am you're good on that have you
had any pets or smoked in the vehicle
no not anything else we should know
about
rotting corpse i don't know how long i'm
not sure how it got there
when i reached in my hand penetrated
through the carcass because it had been
sitting in
uh yeah on the dashboard in the hot sun
for a long time so
uh hopefully you guys have something
like a spray yeah that'd work
get that little pine tree hanging from
the new car
delicious originally was a no-knock
warrant that changed okay this is
important because we need to know too
that the police had to announce
themselves legally they claimed they did
announce themselves
the boyfriend said yep they did knock
but i don't know that they announced
themselves
there's a witness that said that brianna
taylor was not asleep okay
she and her boyfriend both again in the
hallway as she was shot amidst the
return fire there was a crossfire going
on that matters because
simply walking in and shooting someone
you identify is an execution
going both ways where both people are
shot is not the same thing that's not
the same as a hate crime certainly not
the same as a public lynching the
ex-boyfriend glover uh has since
uh sorry not the ex-boyfriend i think
this is the drug
trafficker has been arrested on charges
the boyfriend has a previous
history uh of drug trafficking though we
don't think he had any drug trafficking
here
right right now i also have some
questions wasn't able to find out based
on his previous criminal history how he
had a gun
i don't fully understand it depends from
state to state you can't get answers
because the media doesn't do it do you
have any idea
how many petition for information we
have to sign at a [ __ ] comedy show
this is ridiculous you know with
michigan for crying it's all the time
i'm going like does anyone
know this and people just go no let me
search
it's nowhere right i have to i have to
go through a government portal to ask
for it i have to see what this i have a
fake ring doorbell sketch of the police
an
rbg in a weekend of bernie's shirt
and i'm doing brian stelter's job still
straight
we're asking a lot of you stephen this
is steven's message telling me to go
work on the foyer request that's awesome
oh he does have to go work
lawyer has to go here today because we
do keep him busy with legal things
you know what i mean all right well look
you know in this case they laid it out
very
very clearly a.g did a fantastic job
saying look here's exactly what happened
he the officer was shot they returned
fire the ballistics confirmed that the
office the officer that shot brianna
taylor who was standing right next to
the person not in another room randomly
getting shot this is all that happened
and when they served the warrant like
you said it wasn't a no-knock anymore
they have a witness that said they
announced themselves
as police that's what they went off of
and also the guy who had lived there
prior
listed it as his place of of residence
that's why they were there in the first
place it wasn't because of briana taylor
was because of her ex-boyfriend he had
listed it as i live here in january
yeah they went to list different
residences like when i did with the
paulie shore criterion
dvd collection i don't want that posted
to my address you don't usually a p.o
box works well though i know everybody
knows
his name and he lives in an apartment so
he has to sign for it's very
embarrassing
[Laughter]
again noticing a trend here no no no
it's just uh underage pornography in the
army now
there you go so uh this is also
by the way i i forgot follow me on
instagram uh where we do a lot of stuff
today it doesn't have anything to do
with news it's just i guess they call
lifestyle you know you might see me in
some panties selling some tea
oh my goodness wow they're ranger
paintings though i use a strainer
and uh here's something interesting as
soon as the louisville protesters they
started marching
uh and then i have some more info that
will peak your interest a u-haul
pulled up and it wasn't even the big
u-haul
yeah and you know they have the money
i'll get to that in a second a small
u-haul pulled up with a bunch of
supplies including riot
shields signs uh which then just so
happened to be
strategically placed at the front of
every single cnn correspondent
but here's the video of the truck and
then there's a real surprise
twist
they're designed to look homemade by the
way don't you love that guy goes help me
with this and the white guy is like well
i have to
i can't deny oh yes massar
[Music]
abolition now yeah i love that love the
creative choices that they made to make
it seem like it didn't come off a
production line but it was homemade
right yeah exactly
my six-year-old have her fling some
crayola on there people apart
right well the lady who uh was handing
it out that we don't know this for sure
but it's been confirmed by several
different sources and i again
if it's if i'm wrong on this i won't eat
my hat but i'll make gerald eat a hat
she's been id'd as holly zoller and uh
she's a member of the uh
well i know this might be ben the george
soros linked bail fund project that was
the top twin uh twit twin top
twitter trend yesterday we talked about
biden in a bit by the way
your blood pressure right now is
probably a little high
it makes it hard where they bail out
felons who commit
crimes that night riot and protest it's
like a revolving door it's like the
revolving door and elf
only they're committing rape and arson
just ah
raper arsenal baseball battle mace
that's what they're doing people like
this
bail them out it was the top trend on
twitter yesterday we have to bail these
people out
and we know that these celebrities and
politicians have bailed out people
who've gone on to commit
murders and other felonies and rapes so
good on you
yeah thanks for making those in a black
community more safe seems that you
didn't heed the words of tupac
tupac actually talked about this despite
the fact that he was a drama geek wasn't
really a gangster
he talked about half his you think only
white people care about the violence in
your communities we have to live next
door to it
of course we want someone to do
something about it but the police aren't
showing up in our neighborhood
that used to be the complaint the police
aren't showing up to help us the police
response time in this neighborhood
is really rough why don't we get the
same kind of help that white people get
that's what tupac talked about that's
what a lot of these people talked about
a lot of civil rights
activists were complaining about and
there was a legitimate grievance now
they're saying
hey we want the ability to harm all
other members of our community
without the police officers showing up
if i commit forced
sodomy i would like to see a social
working counselor please
it's like an antifa fantasy league where
they just like bail people out to get
them back on the streets let's get some
more
carnage going for this guy he writed it
really well last night we need to get
him back in the
fantasy league my first pick is
rosenbaum serial child rapist
i know that that's the number one draft
gosh good for you
good for you i cannot throw a no not
even a stone
he's not for injury throw a feather i
can't blow a feather
without hitting a serial rapist at any
of these protesters
i can't covet you it's not possible it's
not possible
i can't breathe droplets without hitting
somebody
who hasn't committed a violent crime on
the flip side
where i live where i go to eat where i
hang out where i go to see movies where
i work
i could uh throw a boomerang and i would
hate nothing but law-abiding citizens
yeah they're breaking these windows to
cover up for their filthy consciences
yes it's a coincidence
until they mistake they were behind pcp
and it wasn't taken for confession
you mean the [ __ ] levi's store is not
where i go
to reach final absolution my bad i will
take
all the size 34 36's though and that's
just because
that's enough i am doing it for jesus
christ i see the deal i can't not take
it
all right hit the notification bell by
the way if you're watching on youtube
sorry about starting late today
facebook locked us out we couldn't
stream there and youtube was kind of
half working
um what are your thoughts there because
you kept jumping in there
i i mean stuff like this always
frustrates me it's not that
you know like you said initially the
report's coming out we should always
wait we've said that from day one
based on the evidence that we have and
it's not that they just get that wrong
that's bad enough they don't correct the
record they continue with stuff they
continue with headlines that say
no charges in the case for brianna
taylor that's the headline that they say
people like what i can't believe it and
they don't go and listen to the ag
who by the way is uh is not white right
he's not some white guy and it wasn't a
court full of
grand jury full of white people right it
wasn't a grand jury full of police
officers
a timber log cabin i believe yeah
correcting this would at least help us
out a little bit maybe it would calm
some people down so they don't go make
idiots out of themselves and worse
attack police
is that your concern that people make
idiots out of themselves i said at the
very least yeah at the very least no i'm
more concerned about the murder
that's i mentioned attacking police
officers i would lead with it
i was you know i was building lead with
the price i was building
the murder and rape did i bury him i
buried the lead i don't really care if
someone looks
dumb while doing it i care more about
the
forced penetration gerald the forced
penetration yeah what do you mean
[Music]
being a father has made you soft no it's
not made me
soft that's embarrassing and by the way
we're going to be talking and this is
why we're going to michigan we are going
to michigan on october 2nd i welcome
everyone to show up there
wear your masks if you can we don't want
the governor to have an excuse to shut
us down but you know that's another
narrative where people have been
protesting and violent that
covet has been spreading because the
president hasn't done enough well guess
what michigan has one of the highest per
capita deaths
and the good thing is that we actually
have direct comparisons as far as
population population density
geographic uh location relevancy in the
united states and nothing comes close to
michigan
and we know why and no one's talking
about it so
i don't believe that this idea that
there hasn't been enough action taken
on behalf of governors or on behalf of
the president is what led to the spread
of covet
but i can verifiably make the case to
you and i will michigan
that governor whitmer didn't keep you
safe governor whitmer
killed your grandparents governor
whitmer forcibly proactively
put the most vulnerable among your state
at risk
for political gain because she's
planning an office run and i'll prove it
october 2nd governor whitmer i do not
like you i don't want to be your friend
i have plenty of friends i could use a
few enemies i'm going to exercise my
first amendment right i wish you the
best and i don't think you'll win
re-election
okay let's go to michigan the uh
peaceful transfer of power this is the
other training stupidity there's
anything else on on the riots there
rbg are you starting you you have seen
you're not a uh yeah i'm not a fan of
riots
and as i always say if you want to uh
get those riot numbers down you got to
get the
abortion numbers up a little bit wow
that's horrible wow rbg a little one
note
i mean we have consistently multifaceted
because
you know but yeah no let's be honest
she had one thing and she rode that
horse to the top
um this is another thing i don't even
want to give it much credence but uh i
do want to talk about joe biden and what
he can look for on the debate
uh on tuesday which we'll be covering he
uses some techniques and strategies that
i think are becoming very apparent and i
want you to be looking for them but
before that
i have to address this because it's the
number one fabricated trend that's been
manipulated on twitter for some reason
um they are saying that trump refused
to transfer power peacefully or will if
he lost the election
uh here's the actual clip yeah there is
oh let's grab that clip really quickly
hold on writing in louisville there's
been writing
oh it hates us why does it in many
cities across this country
red and your so-called red and blue
states
just can you just keep hitting play like
commit to making sure that there is a
piece
you is there anybody
yeah try to pull it up that way try to
pull it up that way um so this is
well i guess you know i'll just have to
go in reverse order so do you know if
the other clips are working there
quarterback
uh at this point i don't yeah is this
because uh facebook uh there might be
something
out there to that okay so do we uh yeah
report back
right now they're completely hopefully
get these clips and uh uh steve given uh
uh uh tokenaw and i want you to be
bringing that up all those clips up
let's have reg the bandit doing it sorry
it's a little bit of a disaster today
because of facebook and youtube not
playing nice i don't mess up my flow i
don't want to claim censorship it could
just be a glitch
that was unforeseen by the world's most
effective and largest technology
companies
you know you never know it would be like
me coming in here and forgetting vowels
isn't it part of your oh we don't know
there's an error in the code isn't
that your job zuckerberg is that your
job can you do it from your bungalow we
understand that you're a man of the
people as a millionaire
and you like to drink water insanity can
you make your [ __ ] work
i don't think so is it too much to ask
that you show up and do your job
this is the equivalent to facebook uh
it'd be equivalent to a mcdonald's
worker putting on the crooked cheese and
a filet of fish which by the way happens
every time
and whenever i see it i look at that
crooked piece of cheese and i go you
know what
uh i'm not fighting for 15. yeah it
doesn't look like it's not it's
definitely not worth 15.
nevermind sorry no i thought we had the
clip that's right i thought you liked
fillet of fish nobody likes fillet fish
i don't even know how you know that
jesus is crooked all right and give it a
shot here we go oh okay this is the
first clip first clip okay
there has been rioting in louisville
there's been rioting in many cities
across this country
red and your so-called red and blue
states will you commit to making sure
that there is a peaceful transferal of
power
after the election well we're gonna have
to see what happens you know that i've
been complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster and
but people are rioting do you commit to
making sure that there's a peaceful
transfer
from one side of the ballots and you'll
have a very trans we'll have a very
peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
the ballots are out of control you know
it and you know who knows it better than
anybody else the democrats know it
better than anybody else go ahead
yeah so let's talk about peaceful
transfer this is this is the scenario
where we are
the left and i don't want to be
hyperbolic
they are professional hostage takers
yeah right now
they have said that joe biden should not
concede under any circumstances
whatsoever what hey
what's going to happen if you exercise
your constitutional uh
constitutional right which is entirely
congruent not concurrent congress with
president
all right donald trump and appoint a
supreme court nominee we'll impeach you
well what happens if donald trump wins
re-election well we won't concede
and uh will continue rioting in the
streets and then they go hey
but will you do the opposite of that if
and right now we're going to
force you into a corner where you have
to answer hypothetical that joe biden
somehow my god wins this thing without
crapping his pants and forgetting who he
was every
10 seconds because someone turned on the
microwave and it threw off the metal
plate in his head let's just throw out
that hypo
aesthetical scenario can you tell us can
you tell us if you'd be peaceful oh hold
on a second we have a problem with
mail-in ballots which we know is the
case of course
and instead we try and make it about a
comment from donald trump rather than
the current
actual violence that has been happening
across this country yeah and what he
said is it's not going to be a transfer
it's going to be a continuation which is
showing confidence that he's going to
win yeah exactly and that's what every
single president or candidate who has
ever been asked that question they pivot
to something else you never talk about
one second right now they're talking
about it with uh all morning king and mr
toupee let's see what they have to say
let's see if they're being standing at
that lectern the podium
in the white house briefing room saying
i may not honor
the results of the count uh that begins
40 nights from now was stopped did he
say i'm i won't ask he didn't say what
he said at all very importantly i didn't
hear that let's see
trying to discredit lawful ways of
voting because he is losing
uh the fda remarks yesterday which
are really part of a broad range of
actions the president's taking that
challenge the integrity of the
government
as he tries to defend challenging the
integrity of the government like
not allowing people to vote trying to
ban people from voting the way that they
voted since the beginning of ever
do you mean trying to instill doubt in
our uh in our electoral institutions
like saying we need to do away with the
electoral college
this has been spoken about from top
democratic officials uh as well as
our favorite socialists-in-chief many of
them or saying we need to burn the whole
system down don lemon who let's be
honest as a donor there at least a pool
boy
or are we talking about the uh areas
where they said well you know what we
should not
joe biden should not concede under any
circumstances
they're talking about donald trump
trying to sow distrust on the government
here's what
let me simplify this for you folks i
talked about it yesterday i hate to
repeat myself
but i'm going to do it anyway donald
trump has sown
zero distrust in america's traditional
institutions or constitutional powers
the only distrust that donald trump has
bred and really it's
shined a light on is in the media yeah
that's it
and that's why they want to make you
think that it's donald trump
who is the one who uh who doesn't want
law and order who wants violence in the
streets there's donald trump who won't
concede that it's donald trump
who doesn't value american institutions
no no as a matter of fact if you look on
every single issue let's look at it okay
the supreme court
donald trump values institutions and
traditionalism let's look at the
electoral
college donald trump sees the value and
uh he he he
understands and values the side of
traditionalism second amendment rights
well he sees americans as having that
right
law and order well he doesn't believe
that people should be able to riot
and loot and commit ars in every what
about conceding the election well the
election he just thinks you should go in
and vote
my god yeah oh that is so that is
eerily similar to hitler yeah exactly
like that was my primary gripe with
hitler by the way
it was the voting i don't want to see
you using the german postal service
it's all the burden you must go in
person and vote you've got to train
unless use the trade unless your name
has
a lot of vowels in the in the
do you know any conservative out there
who if donald trump clearly
loses the election right he goes through
whatever process that is whether he
takes it to court to make sure the count
is correct there's nothing wrong with
that by the way that's what gore did
back when
gore right if he goes through the
process and loses do you know any
conservative that would be willing to
throw everything away and say no he's
not leaving we're just going to let him
stay in power
nobody would do it i don't know a single
person has come out and said that they
would say yeah he loses the election he
can stay in power
that's obviously not what he's talking
about but they're not giving him the
benefit of doubt you know who they did
give the benefit of the doubt to
hillary clinton when she said don't
concede under any circumstances
well i don't think hillary meant stay
there and never let anybody else and
maybe jump the fence and run into the
white house she'll claim your president
i don't think she did she absolutely
argued that she was going to do it like
naked running man
the camera would just pan away you don't
want to give them that audience
but cnn never covered that as being oh
my gosh
joe biden is going to just assume the
presidency even if he loses and yet what
we see with donald trump is that logic
goes out the window
context goes out the way hold on a
second someone will take that out of
context where you see what we see with
donald trump as logic goes out the
windows
conservatives to start protesting this
show because being a dad has made you
soft
i'm not soft their coverage of donald
trump has no logic to it of course he
didn't mean that he's been speaking out
against
mass mail-in ballots because god forbid
texas has 95 000 non-citizens
right now we're going to do a segment on
that next week i personally
personally i know we have statistics
we've talked about how mail-in voting
has been an absolute disaster not
absenteeing voting
i know somebody whose father has been
dead for years received his father's yes
could you send it and now vote uh
vote done yeah he's still alive yeah
sure
you don't know i have i have the
screenshots we'll run that monday
personally it's hysterical and
frightening
and that's all he's pointing to he's
saying i want your votes to count if you
vote and you say that i'm not gonna be
your president fine when january comes
we're gonna put some other guy in here
but what's gonna happen his comment
about getting rid of the ballots was not
getting rid of votes that people have
cast no it's making sure
that your vote counts not somebody else
who's ballot harvesting
and when that happens well that's not
even what it is listen if you ask a
fighter you ask any fighter this is it's
a very simple analogy you don't ask that
kind of a question you ask a fighter
who uh is let's say fighting a number
one contender spot and then about to
fight for the championship and you say
hey uh
this is uh if you win this fight are you
thinking about the heavyweight
championship they always answer
it would be a mistake to overlook my
current opponent i'll think about that
now and we'll talk about that when we
get there
that's how you answer these things
especially if someone asks the
hypothetical
in which you get your ass kicked by a 90
year old with dementia you're not going
to answer your question on your point
let me and i want to go to your way but
let's just really quickly will they talk
about donald trump's showing distrust
who is it who is it that's been
fomenting actual violence
and and distrust in the american system
well because it just so happens we have
a super cut
and please show me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite
and peaceful we will as per chief jim
hopper
punch some people in the face when they
seek to destroy
you first it's a big enough target
and everyone beware because they're not
gonna stop it is gonna they're not gonna
stop before election day in november and
they're not gonna stop
after election day and that should be
everyone should take note of that
and if you see anybody from that cabinet
in a restaurant in a department store
at a gasoline station you get out and
you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they are not
welcome anymore anywhere
yeah the black lady maxine waters is
saying your cans not
welcome here or anywhere how absolutely
eerie wait come on do they miss cast
roots
[Laughter]
i was more finished you said gasoline i
expected to have a three-prong
store just like build build build that
jack what is that
you create a crowd and tell them if they
aren't welcome here and here's something
too when people say oh
because of donald trump's rhetoric uh
people out there have now been violent
and we have white supremacy
i can't point to any rhetoric that is
remotely
similar now we're not talking about a
campaign because i'd like to punch that
guy in the face which the left has also
done as we just showed you but maxine
waters you have an
actual official saying create a crowd
create a mob and let them know that they
aren't welcome here and guess what
people have done
that exactly that i haven't seen donald
trump say hey by the way all cops
i want you to go out and shoot blacks
just make sure your body cams are off
there is no direct correlation in
causation
action equal reaction from donald trump
and
violence that you would see on the right
if it existed it doesn't exist on mass
like the left
as you see from the the rhetoric from
leftist
elected officials and the behavior of
their constituents
i'm sorry it's not a hunch anymore it's
not a theory
she said create a crowd let them know
that they're not welcome that's exactly
what people have done we've shown you
over
we've shown you hundreds of instances of
that happening that guy says go out and
punch them in the face
uh kamala harris uh first pos uh a vp
candidate
goes out yes at pos she goes out and she
says we wanna see more of these
riots and we see more of them react
action reaction it's clear as day
show me that example right now on the
right and guess what if some neo-nazis
go it doesn't qualify it doesn't qualify
because donald trump said
neo-nazis should be condemned totally
they're horrible people sorry
horrible people terrible and he made it
very quick maxine waters didn't do that
no not at all
they haven't come out and said that the
writers are horrible people or that
antifa are horrible people even though
they've been
they've said something that people
should protest peacefully but they
haven't taken aim at the actual
organizations right now who are
responsible for the violence
and again while we're talking about
holding the american institutions
hostage
in case you've forgotten what did they
say about joe biden if he loses the
election which is looking increasingly
likely
well here's what you can expect you know
joe biden should not concede
under any circumstances because
i think this is going to drag out
mentally
eventually i do believe he will win if
we don't give
an inch yeah that woman is mentally
handicapped you know when you're when
she's going like this
it's like you know there's i've worked
with special needs people the nerd
the biomechanical neurons are misfiring
they're not telling her how to act
and you know hillary clinton she's like
i haven't done anything i haven't done
an interview in a while they say oh i
want you to never
give me a retirement person or
transgender whatever it is i just need
to check some boxes if i'm going to come
out and say that joe biden
should concede under no circumstances
it's two old women on a skype call so
they added some traps yeah they got
some music gosh they sell bubble tea in
this trap place
desperate again they just use the piece
of the effect on editing and put cardi
b's
and by the way people telling me it's
rap i know you [ __ ]
i use the champions i use whichever
pronunciation is most offensive
in those circumstances as well you
should because it's funny all donald
trump has done is point out what's
happening
and apparently now that is inciting what
is happening it's like no i'm not
inciting anything i'm just i'm saying
look look the building's on fire like oh
why did you put the building i mean go
to cnn here really quickly because they
have a four they have a quadrant view
with completely unqualified hacks
obviously up next well that's every day
outrage across the country that after no
charges no offices were charged directly
approaching the march
brianna that's their summary did they
just say no charges
no officers were charged in her death
and that's true okay they said well
listen no sisters were charged directly
okay
john king can't be bothered to add the
single extra phrase
no officers were charged directly with
her death though they were charged with
i threw up on my mouth a little bit the
truth is acidic
it's acidic to me at cnn well and and
protests erupt that's just a dishonest
lower third
weird summary of what happened last
night we saw clips of this right yeah
protest erupted makes you think it's
spontaneous a lot of
you see a lot of spontaneous caroling
where a u-haul pulls up with dickens era
costumes and candles
and print sheets there's nothing
spontaneous about you gotta rent those
ahead of time
there was a spontaneous three months in
spontaneous protest that included 90
of the same spontaneous protesters in
seattle portland austin yeah
they're migrating spontaneous protests
more of a flash mob
yeah they do travel in hurricanes they
go south in the winter
flying v knuckle puck time what are you
talking about it's cnn no one watches
nobody cares
speaking of which um here's one thing
too joe biden joseph biden we need to
get to this because he's running for
president obviously we'll be talking
about the debates
uh a little bit more but we will be
broadcasting the debates
on tuesday um
it's gonna be great there have been so
many guests there was one recently that
just happened that i think is i think
people need to be
fair that people said was a gaff and it
wasn't really a gaffe this interview
that came out right and you might have
seen it
what what i missed one and listen we're
better than that we don't need to try
and hang people on miss speaking
it wasn't a gaff joe biden especially
when you understand what was going on
with the prompter he was just distracted
so let
let's show you the full context
deportations freeze deportations for the
first hundred days
and then and only people will be
deported are people who committed a
felony
while here that's number one let me get
that right you are going to
freeze
like okay i lost that yeah well it's but
that's good because
a lot of people don't like joe biden to
be what he is but it do
i am disgusted um and here's something
that i've noticed with joe biden
okay he does a lot and no one's calling
him on it because
this this is a tactic that only works i
was talking with reg the bandit about
this
it only works that the media carries
your water okay yeah uh and the
the tactic that he uses the technique
and i do appreciate that it's sort of a
coping mechanism with his dementia
um is when he starts talking himself
into a corner
sure he doesn't correct it
he doesn't try and sort of reverse
course or try and readjust and go let me
get to that
point anyway let me find another way you
know like congruent and concurrent
you know yes yes i haven't been taking
my jellyfish pills so this is what
happens
i don't know i've been watching too much
cnn yeah jellyfish
something there for your brain i don't
know about my my house for some they're
paying me right now for my house
thank you tom selleck amazing i work
online but i watch cable i live a very
bizarre life
so what he does is when uh
joseph biden gets himself into a corner
he gets tough he does real talk yeah so
he goes hey and
you know when uh when we're talking
about the 100 years in
and the bcna you don't care about that
listen that's what he does yeah exactly
he tries to just also
go through it ah i don't need to go
through the details and facts and bicker
about
ooh you know the thing and he tries
everything he's one of the folks
even though he probably hasn't met a
folk in 35
55 years and i wanted to show you some
examples of this so you can know to
watch for it going forward
because any time you see him abandon his
train of thought and just go
look listen or try and get tough or
shoot straight from the shoulder as he
says
um you know that he's actually lost
his train of thought and the media will
never call him on it
so here's actually uh the first example
i have five examples of this have you
guys noticed that he does this does
everybody have
he gets angry look it's entertaining
look come on guys
i mean cut listen listen that's kind of
like when you ever see like
the fights i get these riots or like
they're like uh you ain't welcome here
hey listen let me you ain't welcome here
hey listen you ain't welcome here but
you ain't well they just keep peace out
over and over especially
very loudly i am not quick on my feet
i can't think of anything to say i wrote
a sign and i'm saying that again
you are playing chess and i am playing
checkers
king me what it's a rook king damn it
all right
so here is the first one where he talks
about the truths and the thing watch his
behavior and we'll show you the pattern
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men and women created
by the go you know the you know the
thing that's a classic
no people behind him were possibly like
what the no
wait what he just said no i don't know
no i don't know the thing
can you tell me the thing oh you're just
trying to do
what what am i trying to do you're just
trying to what am i trying to stop
it's like the alphabet it's like a b c
you know the
alpha you can finish it what the
alphabet what are you talking about you
know and the cereal what
lucky charms you're just naming things
that are somewhat connected
look look luck of the irish
guys guys look i used to take you out
back behind the locker room you're
saying you want to bang me
ah fight what
what do you tell muhammad ali huh joe
frazier you're just naming things
propter are you naming things in the
room i love
prompter the next example uh
and this is recent and i don't think
this was a gaff well it's the pledge of
allegiance i think he had no intention
of saying the pledge of allegiance
because he doesn't know it
but oh no i don't think he was planning
on saying the pledge of allegiance and
lost his train of thought i thought
i think that he was trying to again
create a predetermined defense mechanism
with uh i don't know the pledge of
allegiance so i'll just kind of start it
and sort of act like i'm being flippant
and then move on and hopefully no one
will call me on it and they didn't
so here's that clip i pledge allegiance
to the united states of america
one nation indivisible under god for
real
for real for real no because i thought
it was
for fake real talking
vacation yeah she just starts saying the
pledge i love it i thought that it was
for fake
i was very confused thank you for
clarifying it while we're on the subject
of clarification
um i think i've forgotten some parts of
the pledge of allegiance hey
former vice president of the united
states could you help me out
yeah just fill in those blanks in fact
i'll give you the entire
blue ray set of schoolhouse rock and 15
minutes to find it
you just need to recite what you watched
while following the bouncing demented
idiot
he'd be interested in that all right
here's another one where he had this
mental illness clip he does the same
thing
from this recent town hall it's just
again you notice this he you can see him
going oh crap
i'm reaching the end of his sentence and
i don't know where i'm going with this
because i don't remember where i started
or how i got here say
anything else here you go look we
learned drug abuse isn't
that doesn't cause mental illness mental
stress and
mental and mental illness cause drug
abuse
we've learned so much that we could
change so much and that's why we ought
to
have to make sure that the the super
wealthy start paying their fair share
so we can do the things we have to do to
make life better for
better for hard work and middle class
folks
well if we've learned so much thank god
you're not the teacher
i am he goes i know we've learned so
much
what do you mean we've learned from what
you've just said i learned anything
you need to pay their fair share well
you're rich by the way anyone else find
it ironic that of course he's like no
one over
400 000 will be paying more in taxes
what's the presidential
salary [ __ ] you demented old circus
monkey
it seems like you're right around that
cut-off the only difference is you've
been suckling at the public tea you've
never made it in the private sector from
people
willingly offering you money for goods
or services ah
no one who makes no one who makes any
less than
my exact salary will pay more in taxes
that's never been the cut off that's
never been that number how'd you come up
with that number we have learned a lot
research
look we know the things we need to do
bank statements look look
you can meet me out by the bike racks
well will you have 400 000 for me
tax free what are you saying
all right uh here's another one same
thing this is a pattern and i want
everyone to notice that you can feel
free to rip this clip rip these things
and post them and
i don't care if it's not proprietary i
just want everyone to be on call i want
everyone to be on deck noticing this and
sending it directly to joe biden's
advisors
so that they get in his head and box
them in and say hey you know that thing
that you do
every single time you say something
really stupid you have to stop doing
that because people notice it
and then you'll hear the actual sound of
his body being squeezed like a tube of
toothpaste as he soils himself
in a relieving kind of defecation that
one can only describe as transcendent
just a big
ah yeah
here's another one where he was asked
something about this one is just more
nonsensical but again
he's trying to speed up and sound like
he's one of the people and off the cuff
and that's where he's really bad and so
then he says things
that not only don't make sense in this
context they've never made
i propose and i'm going to digress
slightly like here we
we're in a situation i the president
asked me to head up a cancer moonshot
watch a cancer moonshot do you mean for
yourself
was the president telling you that they
had uh
cancer moon shots is that what he was
saying and by the way did you
misunderstand that the current president
barack obama at that point was trying to
tell you
that you had brain cancer you
interpreted it
barack obama joe i think you want to
maybe get uh checked for some brain
cancer
moonshot noise brain cancer moonshot
uh let's go with that and then he's just
like you know what he's gonna
he probably won't be alive the next time
usually it's the vp who's gonna be
running but it'll be hillary and then
he'll be long gone
in a jacket and a room with felt white
walls
it's it's so sad that people allow him
to do that like this is the very best
that we have i mean
is there any other time in history that
a guy that was this incompetent that's
the democrats
well it's probably hey we didn't say
that you did primaries
right you voted for this guy as the best
among all of you
but he would never in any other
presidential election like this guy we
would be like
he can't be there's no way right we got
to pick the socialist over this guy
because this guy will get in the white
house
he's there playing both when you have to
look at the double-edged sword
i'd be pissed if i repeat butt kick i'd
like hold on this is the guy
i can speak the only the only sin i
committed is i like [ __ ] yeah
i thought you guys liked that i'd rather
hire a demented old circus monkey
than an articulate clean-cut man who was
generally likable
but i happen to like the d that was my
disqualifier
exactly he should register as an
independent and i'd welcome him with
open arms
right hey so who's who's more pissed off
the guy that lost to joe biden for this
or the guy that lost to stelter for the
lead role at uh
cnn what's the same guy oh really it was
pete buck
really breaking gosh two heartbreaking
losses in a row that that's why
he's very upset and with good reason
uh here's another one uh who for many of
you may have forgotten because i know
some of you are younger and you haven't
been following joe biden for a long time
i was following him back during the
primary when he was running against
obama and said his racist stuff back
then
it was hilarious and i don't think by
the way i don't think that joe biden's
racist i actually i really don't think
he's a racist i think that he says
racist things which i find hilarious
because i know old people and i know
plenty of old people who are not racists
but they say racist things because it's
just they're you know what
they're all oh they care at this point
they're confused they also steal
a lot i don't know if you know this old
people steal because what are you going
to
do
lock them up yeah no one else does
anything with old people put me away
cover for this whenever
i'm old i am going to be a kleptomaniac
that's what oh and it's not even what i
want to do no it's just
it's just the flow of life so many of
you don't remember this
uh his quote about the double-barreled
shotgun and again in this this he does
the same thing back then but i hadn't
noticed it it wasn't as severe
but he starts talking and he notices
wait a second uh get a double-barreled
shotgun fired into the air and he
realizes oh i just
advocated something seriously illegal uh
listen
you don't need any changes subject in
another nonsensical way
so jill if there's ever a problem just
walk out on the balcony here or walk out
put that double barrel shotgun and fire
two blasts felony outside the house i
promise you who's ever coming in is not
gonna
you don't need an ar-15 it's harder to
aim
it's harder to use and in fact you don't
need
30 rounds to protect yourself that's not
a fact
that's not a fact you fired in the air
let me redirect
it's harder it's harder to use it's
harder to aim well aiming is one of the
primary uses of firearms so i assume
that he kind of covered it but i get it
it's okay you're about 94. we'll give
you a pass
because and fact oh fact firearm fact
i'm a firearm efficient so
maybe there's something i don't know you
don't need 30 rounds oh no see that's
not a fact that's an [ __ ] opinion
well and how many people are there right
how many people does that could be
relevant
recently there's a lot there are some
studies that show the average number of
shots to hit somebody is seven depending
on which studies you use they don't have
the sources available
but it's certainly more than one and
there are studies that show that people
who commit armed robbery usually more
than one i don't
have the source but i saw the town right
and the point here
is let's say there are five people 10
people
well it's 30 rounds at that point
absolutely seems conservative so when
when someone says fact and then it's not
a fact that's a problem i always tell
you when i say hey opinion uh you know
what this is just conjecture this is an
opinion
and when i say fact usually it's
preceded by a fact
yes well and basically he just thinks
it's like a duel where nobody moves and
you just kind of like stand there and
take a shot at each other
right so you just don't need 30 anymore
just stand there and take it which by
the way i don't think how duels were
actually
i think that's what it happened that's
what they did in the film it's like
quick draw i think they did it because
john wayne had a limp and walked kind of
gay really
yeah john wayne's there hey the duke
series
is there anyone any more masculine than
the duke show show him your gate
he just got up a horse yeah he's got the
bow-legged horse
all right and here's another one my
personal favorite that's recent and the
media has tried to sweep under the rug
uh and one would say probably most
relevant because if we're talking about
president donald trump not doing enough
in regards to covet and i i can
understand that you
you feel that way you think that i
understand that there's an argument to
be made i think it's a bad argument
but i understand why people are saying
it however if you are making that
argument you can't say we should replace
him with the guy
who uh doesn't know what year it is how
many deaths have occurred with kovid
or uh the fact that uh covid has not
killed hundreds of people
over thousands of years in other words
you can't have it both ways
here's a clip covert has taken this year
just since the outbreak has taken more
than
100 years look here's the lives
it's just it's i mean think about it
more lives this year than any other year
for the past hundred years huh
think think about you first just you
know what's your job just i don't even
need you to finish the thought
just start just make it to the midway
point
if it were a map on the back of a kid's
menu at ihop
i just expect you to get around the
spiral i don't need you to make it all
the way to the dolphin
just get halfway there bye this is what
he does you know he does the same thing
look look listen but here's the thing
tell me the thing
i don't know the thing we'll see that's
the problem i think the president
should know the thing at least some of
the matters
i mean i had not seen that clip and i'm
just like what
in the last what was the what was the
logical point that he was going to make
it's taken more lives than anything else
in the last hundred years
there's nothing that fits that listen
there's nothing i will be clear
because sometimes i blur the lines you
do of satire
and effect and that right rbg yes that's
uh that's true yeah but
i would also like to add joe biden i
know him personally he's a
sharp young man and without any further
substantial evidence i would have to
conclude these are all
deep fakes right well she's so even
though
she's not quite dead she'll she'll be
voting for joe biden um for sure
well yeah not quite yeah she's she's
mostly several times she'll be voting
for joe biden
no with joe let me just say this okay
there's a difference between sat and i
appreciate you clarifying satire and i
blur the lines
so let me be clear here in watching that
where he says 100 years and the deaths
in the covid uh
more than any hundred years not fact
joe biden has dementia okay i cannot
confirm that just because we can't get a
doctorate
green room because brian stelter is like
a hockey goalie
stopping you from getting stop it please
stop
it he needs his space he's been
campaigning for
25 minutes he has to did you see that
joe biden stopped campaigning one day at
like 9 30 in the morning this week he's
called a lit i think almost every day
before noon it was like eight thirty and
that third
say what you want about donald trump
that guy has energy for days
yeah yeah you may not like what he says
but he does a lot where he invests his
energy
he works all day as president and then
does a two-hour
rally right yeah incredible exactly then
when he's done he unwinds with a diet
coke while tweeting
yeah the guys that's the rocket the
guy is the t2000 of abrasive [ __ ] if
you're a democrat stop
he just can't stop he's people never
sleep
while his other arm is tweeting
that's impressive he just makes another
arm you can do that when you're liquid
metal
that happens one of my favorites for
john connor uh
so anyway i expect to see this a whole
lot in the debate we're going to be
covering this all of tuesday night it
starts at uh i believe 8 30 8 30 eastern
yeah we're going to start the stream a
little bit early to offer some
commentary i want you to be looking for
that
a lot of people have been speculating as
to what will happen on the debate stage
here's the thing
if if joe biden actually shows up in
person on that debate stage with donald
trump
i will never be so happy as to have been
wrong the only prediction i made was
that great won't show up in person i
thought he would do a zoom call like
hillary clinton with the
special needs lady and i don't say that
i don't say listen i don't
i think that's actually the case there
yeah um so i think
stop laughing i think it's i'm throwing
i'm extending an olive branch to audio
you're a horrible person that says more
about you it does
um a lot of people are speculating as to
what might happen
uh in the debate and um we don't know
exactly i want you to watch for these
tactics but we do actually have an
exclusive um
computer modeling projection of the
debates
uh when we entered in all of the valid
uh data and uh the analytical
information that we had
uh the computer which is a you know they
use it like for boxing for line yeah
yeah yeah yeah
very helpful this is the projected
computer simulated matchup
i was going to say italian but you know
you never know you do realize i speak
french correct
he said it i wasn't talking to you i was
talking to him is it french oh he's
french
he's my uncle that's private video
sad that's a set
and let me explain to you why it's
hysterical because you stupid
anglophones that's what us french
canadians call english speakers
don't understand the context the guy who
throws the punch
he's yelling at he's going all right you
see all right let's go let's and the guy
goes
the guy literally says no no no put that
down basket goes no no i don't have any
intention of fighting come on we're
adults and i was oh yeah hold this you
little [ __ ] come on
no stop stop stop then the guy swings
the other guy sidesteps and he falls
like if you fall flat right yeah
that's bad but if you're planted here
you fall that's further
further further it's a decline and the
guy probably
is still doing better than actual biden
yes
it is a hilarious clip i don't care and
this is but this goes back to i don't
care
about the power differential i care
about who's right and who's wrong
and even if an old man just vaporizes
his hip
i do not have a problem with it if he is
the one saying let's go i'm going to
kick your ass and the guy's saying no no
come on come on man i don't want to
fight i don't want to fight
i don't care if it's sad that is
justice um you know what we
are going to come here with some of your
chats we do have to go this is the last
week just so you know
uh of the david dorn t-shirt is it is it
louder with creditshop.com
livecrottershop.com we have sold we have
raised a lot of money
good so the wife ann dornan is actually
going by her request to a scholarship
or a fund in david doran's name so she
wanted me to know that it's not actually
going to her
which is just another these people are
salt of the earth and i really do
appreciate them especially now when it's
open season on officers
uh this will be the last week you can
get the david dornish shirt loud with
cuttershop.com
uh a quick break from our sponsors we'll
come back with your chats and some
exclusive info
retired st louis police captain david
dorn doran was shot and killed by a
looter earlier this week in north st
louis this was a great cop
great cops do exist and this is one of
black lives have to matter to us first
so until then
we're gonna keep on having these
instances of
stupid killings and stuff like that
my uncle didn't deserve to die like that
hey garrett just so you know stephen
moved the taping back 30 minutes
all right thanks man great man thanks
for thanks for the heads up appreciate
it
[Music]
[Music]
hey garrett we actually are gonna need
brony
at least what you do online is your
business protect your business with
[Music]
expressvpn
uh well we by the way we are really
grateful to expressvpn for sponsoring
the show we've actually used
if you can go back and look at our some
of our videos that revolved around uh
youtube search algorithms the chelsea
stuff when we were searching for stephen
crowder changed my mind and he couldn't
find it and
youtube was like thanks for letting us
know we fixed that well what'd you fix
well that's classified
uh we were using express what a
coincidence before they were ever a
sponsor
um and really that's about if you want
to make sure that big tech
again these are these are companies
right now when you look at the big three
are more powerful than any government oh
yeah in any previous century
make sure what you do online is
protected expressvpn is a great way to
do it they have the balls to sponsor
this show
and i believe you get uh you get three
months free
if you sign up at expressvpn.com crowder
i want to make sure the
expressvpn.com crowder the reason i need
this in writing is because i just have
it installed on my computer and my
phones yeah so i always forget the
landing where you need to go once you
install it you just use it
super easy to use it's what we use and
um they also
are as far as i understand it uh one of
the only major
uh security express vpns i was about to
say security express the word i was
looking for was vpn
now look expressvpn you know a
they're one of the only vpns who
advertise on podcasts on
youtube who didn't have a security
breach that they would help from the
public
so i'm not going to name names but let's
just refer to it
as uh brand x yeah but by the way there
are
there are tons of brands lining up to
get joe biden as their spokesperson
right you know go to the with the phone
he's so used to reading prompt or we can
put anything in there and he'll just say
it
and it doesn't matter if it's illegal oh
my gosh all right we're going to go to
your chat
really quickly uh we do these chats
exclusively uh with mug club members
again you can sign up at lot of
cutter.com
mug club where we were broadcasting
today before we got locked out of
facebook and youtube so that's the fail
safe it's the only thing that keeps this
going
and uh so we don't do super chat because
i don't want to give the uh i don't want
to give the volcanic big tech overlords
my money
volcanic all right ian's i assume
they're scientologists
the thetans ian says do you think the
resurgence in riots due to the brianna
taylor verdict will help trump win
close rust belt states or minnesota i
certainly don't think that it hurts i
don't know if he will win
um if you look at the electoral map
there are a lot of ways that donald
trump can win
and there there is really kind of a
preset path for
joe biden to win if donald trump does
win florida and the polls are having him
ahead
uh right now in florida the more recent
polls i know the rolling average isn't
but if you look at the trend the more
recent polls show him closing it
especially if you look at the
demographics with latinos and with
black people in the state um if donald
trump wins florida
there are multiple paths for him to win
and all of them do involve some
midwestern states though but that can be
a combination of minnesota
wisconsin or michigan or michigan and
pennsylvania
i was very surprised at michigan in the
last election um i wouldn't be surprised
with it going
either way this go around but that's
also why we're going to the capitol on
october 2nd because the one leg that
governor whitner has to stand on and for
some reason michiganders have
bought this [ __ ] is you see all these
signs thank you governor whitner for
keeping us safe
by the way she must be using a vpn
because they have no record of the
numbers
they have no record of the death numbers
of seniors in michigan and no other
numbers make sense
hopefully we'll get them but we do have
some numbers that might interest you
the only leg that she has to stand on
democrats in michigan is this message
that they are pumping that donald trump
didn't do enough to stop covid
whereas their governor took actions
proactively
that killed people i'm not saying she's
a murderer her policies
killed people you can contrast it by any
other metric you use
population population density amount of
major cities
amount of land mass geographic location
by any other metric michigan
is not even close uh it's an outlier
yeah
and her policy is that of an outlier
governor yeah and hopefully somebody
who's out of office
very very soon and an outright liar yeah
exactly
i think you're right i think there's no
win for the democrats on the riots
they they look bad because they don't
they don't typically come out and
condemn the writing
tend to support these things or at least
push them a little bit and every time
people get scared that are independents
they get scared for their safety and
security they tend to run towards
republicans so yeah
on the issue of security it helps donald
trump i don't know that he will win all
the midwestern states
uh i wouldn't be surprised to see him
pick up some yeah if he wins if he wins
florida and pennsylvania it's done
uh if he wins florida and then just
maintains the
states that lean republican but aren't
necessarily dead locks
then he can win uh either minnesota
wisconsin or michigan any and he wins
so there are a lot of paths for him to
win um
and you know listen people say the po
and i don't know about the polls but i
will say when the polls
if you look at rcp they have texas and
they had missouri up until this week as
toss-ups well then you have to throw
them out completely
i will certainly eat my hat if missouri
votes for joe biden
you find me the biggest abe lincoln cat
in the hat you can find me a kid
in a hat and i will eat said hat and the
cats
missouri and that's how you know that
polls are at least trying to manipulate
public opinion and when people say there
aren't nearly as many secret trump
voters as there used to be well i don't
know
listen i think that in 2016 trump wasn't
unknown so maybe people kind of didn't
know where they were leaning but as far
as secret trump voters
in 2016 people weren't shot in the head
point blank for voting trump
yeah so i think some people might keep
it to themselves and i know at least
50 to 100 people who watch this show say
yeah i just can't talk about it and i
just
i don't tell people but i'm gonna
definitely vote donald trump i wouldn't
answer a poll that's anecdotal
and statistically if you look at their
sampling averages they are
pretty damn biased and tilted towards
the democrats i think they consider it
balanced because they include more
independence but certainly not
republicans
let's go to another chat please justin
says do you think open carry protests
cause more harm than good for defending
to a rights
what should conservatives who
desperately want to protect these rights
do instead well you know it's
interesting because we had a video
planned on this
right we did on location before kovid
and uh i will say this
i'm not going to condemn people who uh
go out and carry long rifles okay i
understand that that is their right
absolutely and i don't believe that it
should be infringed upon
however if our goal is to draw more
people into the fold into the second
amendment community we want more people
to carry firearms
um i do think that it's
counterproductive so i hope that i've
made my position clear i'm not saying
that you're wrong i'm not saying that
i'm against it
but i do think first off i prefer
concealed carry because it's surprised
uh but i also think that if you're going
to open carry that's not how people
would open carry in everyday life i
think that maybe we will see some people
uh open carrying maybe in higher numbers
now but they're not gonna be walking
around with an ar-15 they're more likely
to have
a shoulder holster or maybe they have a
hip holster that's outside of a tucked
in shirt with a pistol on their hip
so i think that open carry protests
should try and be as close to mimicking
how people could see themselves
exercising that right
and not people who look like you know
backyard paintballers playing militia
and i'm not saying it's morally wrong
i understand what i would like to see
and we were planning on doing this
right a more realistic open carry but
then you know there was a
a bad flu yeah yeah yeah because then
these guys are
threatening and they're just like what
it's legal yeah yeah i don't know
i couldn't hear you through your skull
uh your skull
neck gator i don't enjoy this
conversation
that's an awkward encounter yeah one
more chat yeah absolutely sean
uh says antifa just launched some
attacks in north carolina near me
at what point do uh we citizens need to
pick up the
responsibility for protecting our state
when our leaders fail to do so
um that's a good question we've talked
about that quite a bit in the show
listen i
i will never advocate that you do
something illegal on this program
because there are people who are just
aching to ban me or put me in jail
but i will say this i definitely uh
encourage support and would like to see
more homeowners and business owners
rightfully lawfully protecting what is
theirs i'm not talking about going out
and hunting people who you disagree with
i'm not even talking about going out and
uh not even playing vigilante but going
out and playing peacemaker with a gun
even if you go to a riot and your goal
is to try and quell the riot you bring a
firearm that's not what happens
but i do want to see more americans i do
want to see massive numbers of americans
when people stroll through your
neighborhood
and break into your house or break into
your business i would like to see more
americans exercising their second
amendment rights and defending what is
theirs
why so that other americans aren't
afraid to do so
i'm not i i make no apologies for
stating that i hope that i've been very
clear on where i line up
i want you to protect what is yours and
you know what there are a lot of
communities where i know where they're
um
you know we used to have block parents
in canada i don't know if that's a thing
here but
community watch programs in your
neighborhood you get with other people
who are gun owners
and uh or people who have alarm systems
some people just have alarm systems
in these watch programs where if you
have a break-in and you don't have the
money for an alarm system you call them
and they hit a button that alerts the
police
so uh it would be good to get with
people in your community
and have a plan and have a strategy to
protect your family to protect what's
yours
or your business community don't go out
and look for a fight don't even go into
a fight that's already happening
i'm sorry that your governments have
abandoned you eventually that'll be the
president's job to send in the feds
everywhere but you do have the right and
it's different from state to state but
it's your god-given right
to protect your family and your property
and i do encourage everyone to do that
no apologies
uh thank you much sean for that i
appreciate it gerald a i appreciate you
being here sir um
i did want to of course let you guys
know that we'll be in michigan again uh
october 2nd and next tuesday
is the huge debate stream but i did want
to take this second just to
to send out a thank you i talked about
it earlier and during the break i
realized i wanted to talk about a little
more
uh people will ask you to check your
privilege um
that's not gonna do that i'm not gonna
do that ever i'm not going to be
checking my privilege solely for being
white but i will recognize
privileges that i've enjoyed throughout
my life that many people haven't for
example have a mom and a dad
i have a mom and a dad who love me and
that is an incredible privilege i think
it's one that's more valuable
than money then assets then a good
school
any a good mom and a dad i am eternally
grateful but i will recognize
that as a white person there is a
privilege that i have
where i can become a police officer if i
so choose
without being considered a race trader
or an uncle tom or my family being at
risk
that's something that's exclusive to
black men in this country who choose to
go out and serve their communities by
the way they do it in a higher
percentage of the police force than the
general population
it's a privilege that i recognize it's
not something generally speaking in the
white community where if i say well okay
do i want to go into the military would
i like to go to college or you know what
i've always wanted to be
a police officer or firefighter but
specifically police officer
the response is generally not without
fail
why would you want to be a cop oh my god
you want to enforce that system no no as
a matter of fact that would be
surprising that reaction if a white
person were to tell his parents
that he wants to become a police officer
it's the rule very often you see right
now in the black activist community now
not the black communities themselves if
you look at the polls
most black people in the united states
actually wants 80 something percent
between 70 to 80 something percent
depending which pole you're using with a
sampling bias
they want to see at least as much police
presence in their neighborhoods
as they have now or more but in the
media if you are a black police officer
you are given no credit and there's a
way i was thinking about that today
watching these protests and watching
police officers get hit in the back of
the head
and watching black police officers
trying to serve their community and
trying to reason with people who
may live next door to them but certainly
have the same same color skin
and the hate that you see in the eyes
of other black people toward black
police officers often in this country
that's got to be a horrible feeling and
we've talked about it on this show but
you know what i think that i've done
a disservice yeah we're selling the
david dorn shirt this is the last week
that will go to the but i don't think
we've talked about enough i think that
we almost
you could almost say that we've
forgotten about black police officers
we've talked about it but my god you
know what that is probably
the main takeaway right now with the
protest or the riots and the police
violence when i think about when i
thought about this this morning what
they have to go through
black officers today in the united
states of america in 2020
it almost brings a tear to my eye
because really when you compare it to
anyone anyone else
on the side of these conflicts whoever
gets who gets the short end of the stick
you can compare white police officers
you compare black
protesters you can compare white
protesters it's not
even close it's not even close the
people who get treated the worst
the people who get no credit from most
communities are the
the black police officers in this
country and you know what that's got to
be a really hard decision to make
think about that for some guy to in 2020
or let's go back a few years or as joe
biden refer to it uh
century let's go back to 2016. a black
guy saying you know what i think i want
to serve my community
i see crime i see drugs i see violence i
want to become a police officer
in 2016 in 2020 that takes a brass pair
and so you know what officers out there
officers i assume that listen you're not
easily offended so i'll just say black
american officers i don't want to say
officers of color because probably kick
my ass and rightfully so you should get
the billy club if i say that black
officers i want you to know
um and i know this may not mean a whole
lot coming from a basic white guy like
myself believe me the irony is not lost
on me
but we everyone here at ladder with
crowder and i know i probably speak for
most conservatives
truly appreciate the sacrifices that you
have made
and namely the biggest sacrifice you've
made which is
your calling your vocation for the rest
of your life you've chosen to do
something
um which is never glorified for which
you're given very little credit and i
want to say this individually as a man
genuinely genuinely i appreciate your
willingness
to make the hard choice to proactively
look down two paths and i don't know if
you could look at a much harder path as
a black man in the united states of
america than becoming a police officer
uh and you chose that one and i know
sometimes you probably i was just
thinking about this this morning
sometimes you probably look around and
you wonder is it all worth it
listen i can't tell you that you'll have
to determine that for yourself
um but i can tell you this
we need you the united states of america
people of all colors
truly need you i can say that i see you
i
recognize you and when it feels like the
world doesn't
um i want you to know that's a media and
democratic division-led lie
the rest of us here do we see you we
appreciate you
your story isn't told enough and i
cannot thank you enough
i appreciate it we will see you next
week thank you again black officers i
won't say officers of color because
you get it subject for today
[Music]
today
[Music]
last one
[Music]
hypnosis
[Music]
um
now let's go once more
loosen up
[Music]
go
nbc